monsieur cette entreprise existe depuis très
longtemps jamais en tant qu'invité libéré a rendu
son existence normale au monde extérieur
combien de temps aurons-nous le plaisir
de recevoir mr.  Doucet en tant qu'invité 20
ans avec ce sentiment de ne pas savoir quand
tu sors tu vois tous les
types de comportement en colère solitaire délirant
mais Josh fait comme un tour de force oui un
policier a été enfermé pendant
longtemps il y a une intensité qu'il est
amener à ce niveau qui est tout simplement
merveilleux a été confronté à ses pires
démons lui-même en faisant beaucoup de jogging
Joe vient de dire que c'est un
rôle très exigeant physiquement j'ai essayé mes articulations j'ai
asséché mes muscles j'ai eu des crampes
horribles pendant environ deux semaines et demie
avant de m'endormir la nuit dernière et de
prendre une livre à la fin, vous perdez ce
poids comme pendant le week-end,
je dois me battre pour moi-même,
ils apportent définitivement cet élément de
physique que je ne suis pas sûr que trop de
gens voudraient apporter des emplois  étaient
des instincts animaux très intuitifs en chacun de
nous
j'ai été époustouflé c'est une expérience
et c'est ce que je veux aller au
cinéma je veux être ému d'accord vous
voudrez peut-être réfléchir à ce que vous
faites  ici j'y
pense depuis 20 ans